et pour en parler nous sommes avec aria
gémeaux activiste kurde indépendant à
rien j'ai mon bonjour bonjour merci au
revoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors on l'a vu les kurdes
réclament une aide internationale pour
juger les djihadistes de dèche
concrètement quels sont les les
différents aspects de cette demande
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui tu as
fait alors ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
les kurdes ça fait maintenant deux ans
qui demande une aide pour justement
pouvoir gérer et donner des procès à ces
terroristes et de dave et durant ces
deux années on a eu les kurdes ont eu
très peu de réponses ils ont eu très peu
de réponses pour des raisons
géopolitiques on va pour a expliqué par
la suite mais c'est douze mille feux
zarka douze mille terroristes dont 3000
étrangers
donc ces personnes là sont venus
d'autres pays ont grandi dans d'autres
pays et sont venus dans un territoire
fait commettre des actes et il ya
également 4000 femmes
il ya eu mille enfants donc à une
complexité particulière par rapport à
ses procès là et donc au niveau
juridiction les kurdes aujourd'hui
essaient tant bien que mal de renforcer
au niveau des lois donc c'est ce qui a
été fait mais ils ont quand même besoin
d'une aide logistique diplomatique et
juridictionnelle car il ya des personnes
qui ne sont pas ni syriens irakiens ni
cure de quoi que ce soit et ce n'est pas
du ressort des kurdes de pouvoir les
juger et on a des aides du moins on a eu
des réunions avec notamment des
ministres finlandais danois ou encore la
belgique n'est encore deux jours pour
discuter de cela est typiquement on
discute on discute mais aujourd'hui rien
n'est vraiment fait il ya des choses qui
bloque ses procédés justement dead
qu'est-ce qui va justement qu'est-ce qui
bloque les procès ces procédés la de
dead jurent-ils juridictionnelle
internationale alors il a des intérêts
économiques et on est aujourd'hui encore
dans une guerre en syrie en réalité la
guerre en syrie c'est ce qui se passe
c'est une guerre mondiale par
procuration tout comme on l'a eue à la
deuxième guerre mondiale ont attendu
qu'elle se soit qu'elle soit fini afin
de pouvoir juger les différents
criminelle aujourd'hui c'est le même
contexte
on a on a du coup encore la guerre qui
se poursuit en réalité au niveau là
aujourd'hui ce niveau dit libre vers à
l'aide
donc on a l'état turc avec les
djihadistes du coup on parle justement
des jets 10 terroristes et sert encore
aujourd'hui le cas avec la turquie qui
les soutient donc on voit tout de suite
que ça peut poser des problèmes au
niveau international car la france et
d'autres pays européens ont des intérêts
économiques avec ce genre de pays et au
niveau 2 de la juridiction sur place
c'est complexe alors on a on voit que la
france a enlisés dans le sujet reste
assez discrète pour le moment pourtant
vous le disiez il y à des prisonniers
d'origine française
comment est ce que vous comprenez ce
silence de la france dans ce dossier là
alors la france allait pour le monde la
moins silencieuse c'est à dire que
clairement macro est monté au créneau à
plusieurs reprises afin de dire qu'il y
avait des ambiguïtés de la part d'un des
alliés de l'otan la turquie sur ses
positions par rapport à ces jihadistes
donc il ya des paroles mais en attendant
au niveau politique vraiment exprès
c'est il n'y a pas d'action il n'y a pas
d'action donc les kurdes ça fait plus de
deux ans qu'ils essayent de juger c'est
de trouver une solution que ce soit la
cour pénale internationale
un tribunal international ou quoi que ce
soit et la france n'a pas aidé jusque là
dans ce sens là donc il ya toujours une
inaction il faudrait selon vous que ces
prisonniers français dont qui ont
combattu aux côtés d'edf soit
aujourd'hui rapatrié en france ça serait
une solution
alors c'est une des solutions
envisageables malheureusement aucun des
pays n'a répondu favorablement à ses
demandes là il ya eu des petites demande
donc par rapport aux enfants donc comme
je le disais à 8000 enfants ce qui
représente en fait une nouvelle
génération de l'état islamique donc il
faut s'en occuper c'est un gros problème
qui va y avoir dans les années à venir
et en 2019
il ya seulement 3% des théories
sedanaise qui sont prisonniers chez les
kurdes qui ont été rapatriés 500 autant
vous dire que c'est une goutte d'eau et
donc cette stratégie de rapatrier
jusqu'à maintenant ça fait deux ans elle
ne fonctionne pas elle n'a pas
fonctionné donc il faut essayer autre
chose
ce que les cures ne peuvent pas
justement maintenir tous ces terroristes
peuvent pas les garder situation de
guerre situation de crise économique et
bombardements de la turquie qui libère
également des terroristes d'alès qui
s'est passé en octobre dernier
donc il faut trouver une solution rapide
parce qu'on le voit l'opinion publique
est largement contre l'idée de ce
rapatriement de j
liz n'est en tout cas en france ça a un
impact selon vous justement sur cette
décision du gouvernement français sur
cette inaction du gouvernement conseil
venez nous décrire alors les kurdes
comme je les dis ça fait deux ans donc
il avait déjà envisagé
on a déjà accepté cette réalité on a dit
d'accord très bien on vous les renvoie
pas dans ce cas-là aidez nous à les
juger chez nous et donc dans cette
perspective la reconnaître à une série
de sons kurdes etc pourrait embêter
certains partenaires et ce qui fait
qu'il n'ya de qui est l'inaction donc
nous on est prêt à le faire on a
renforcé des lois par rapport à ça et
c'est mais ça n'a pas été fait jusque là
demande d'argent également sa demande
des moyens demande d'argent n'a pas été
fait non donc ça demande des moyens plus
juridictionnelle logistique et pour le
monde demande d'argent le nom n'a pas
été fait donc c'est vraiment un problème
juridique pour le moment pour le moment
c'est vraiment un problème juridique est
plus compliqué au niveau d'intérêts
géostratégiques militaire parce que ces
terroristes là aujourd'hui sont
emprisonnés de mincir au sort ça
constitue une force de frappe une force
de frappe qui utilisent la turquie en
envoyant en libye en orient s'est dit la
disto l'ajustement qui ont été libérés
par la turquie donc il ya ces questions
de si on les laisse s'échapper
où est-ce qu'ils vont aller qu'est ce
qu'ils vont devenir comment va
réintégrer ces personnes à la société je
ne pense qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
donc il ya ces problématiques là c'est
un problème qui est très complexe et
donc on pense en les laissant de côté
qu'il va se dissiper de lui-même alors
que cette prime qui est conséquent parle
de 12000 personnes
pas de 8000 enfants 4000 fans donc il
faut vraiment se pencher sur le sujet
pour le résoudre une fois pour toutes
avec l'aide des kurdes qui jusque là ont
été alliés de l'occident sur les mêmes
valeurs de l'occident démocrate et c'est
ce qu'on attend gentil bien sûr alors
pour conclure antonio guterres s à
parler de menace pour les droits de
l'homme la communauté internationale
selon vous est-ce qu'elle prend
suffisamment conscience de la situation
humanitaire aujourd'hui en syrie non
clairement la situation humanitaire en
syrie elle est catastrophique du côté
des camps c'est à dire qu'il faut voir
que on a un manque énorme de moyens on
est dans une situation de guerre donc et
on n'a pas de fonctionnaires aaron
étatique avec des impôts qui vont se
récupère on a déjà du mal à gérer les
prisons en france on attend d'une région
en guerre où il ya des purs d'aller
gérer autant de prisonniers qui sont
extrémistes
c'est pas le même prix zone et qu'on
peut avoir dans les prisons françaises
donc c'est très compliqué merci
coût arias le gémeau d'avoir partagé
votre analyse sur notre plateau je
rappelle que cet activiste kurde
indépendant tu as fait